all right you've probably used paper
straws but what about a paper bottle
I've never seen one I don't think eight
news now reporter Brian will explains
what a liquor company is doing to expand
their business while also reducing their
environmental footprint
that's it it's done it folds down
plastic everything's recycled Brendan
gong his last name may sound familiar
are the gong family here in Las Vegas
that has run casinos he's also a former
race car driver and now the driving
force behind 17A stillery he bottles
demon rum a wisconsin-based spirit
expanding in Las Vegas and these guys
came out and said they they are both
into environmentally friendly type
things they somehow they ran into this
bottle and they said we want to be the
ones where has all the rum gone well
think paper straws this is a first of
its kind paper bottle and everything
about it can go right into the recycling
I gotta tell you very very skeptical
right I mean oh God paper what do I get
myself into the bottle itself turned out
to be very very cool this new bottle is
made in Canada and uses 84 percent less
water to make six times less carbon and
is five times lighter than a glass
bottle of the same size eyes the secret
to keeping the content stored the liquor
is in the plastic bag that does not need
doesn't get soggy doesn't get wet but
even that bag is recyclable demon rum
has committed to planting a tree for
every one of their bottles sold
reporting in Las Vegas Brian will 8 News
Now
so the new Eco bottle will be sold in
stores by Earth Day which by the way is
coming up on Saturday